hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to factorio with Bob say hi
Bob hi hello it's been a long time since
we did a collaborative effort like this
especially since we did one where I had
to know things and/or be good at things
well I guess that's true because and
don't starve neither of us knew things
and neither us did things well so it's
kind of isn't have to do so it was fine
did we did we not have to though because
there might have been some complaints
here and there about our lack of
performance and I seem to recall it
going perfectly
so it went perfectly when we cheated I
don't when the good graces of the
heavens doth descended upon us but
that's besides the point
so anyway this is factorio if you guys
have watched my videos on this you know
that I love this game and bob is now
introduced to the fact oh oh it's so
cool look and pride the conveyor belt
look yeah look
yeah look I'm doing it okay that's not
what I would have call the awesome part
of it but that's really good I got
really worked up about it okay okay
you're talking about Balki I'm probably
nothing but anyway I'm placing oh
they're military finished so now we can
craft not only better guns but I'm
placing turrets around the base to
defend us yeah yeah so I'm gonna
actually dedicate one of these just to
making bullets these turrets oh yeah
these things need ammo okay yeah so you
can either craft up ammo by yourself but
why do that when you can make assembly
machines do it for you
so uh Bob this is about where the point
where you I caught you up to this point
in the game what happens next even at
all yeah so what we researched so far is
about where we left off in the last
episode we just have automation
military's done we have turrets and the
next step is getting logistics so I'm
gonna get that underway because
logistics is gonna get us fast in
Surtur's which actually move a lot
faster than these slow ass burner
inserters and actually i don't know
where i left off with them because i was
playing so much on my own that I
actually am uncertain where
they know but either way it will just
base it off what you know Bob so these
Automator x' where where I said before
our Glee makes science so we put copper
ants yes exactly so I will make another
Automator nope I won't because they
don't have the materials to do that
let's make a whole athletic ears I could
do that yeah you make gears and you
shove them inside of the assembly
machine shove them in there
yeah shove them in there right you're
good we're sciencing the [ __ ] out of
this yeah so that's so that's gonna make
science and the next thing that we're
going to do is we're going to replace
all of our drills and this is where the
overall comes with power drills indeed
yes so if you look in the production tab
there are electric mining drills right
next to the burner mining drills so make
as many of those as you can out of those
ok get the materials in to pick those
I'm so catching up I'm working on it
he's learning and everyone out there is
mining I just want to say I know I'm not
clueless I set up all of this copper
mining stuff well I was doing all this
look at all this setup also while I
accomplished that little tiny amount of
work mark set up all of the rest that's
ok and I don't forget Stoney Stoney up
in the corner oh yes don't me good old
Stoney man good old Stoney here he's old
stoner
he's only got little literally four
conveyer belts to put his stuff on but
he's proud of what he does he's a guy
right so I can make three of those
things so making three of those things I
need to make some power poles to go with
it right yes exactly not such as wood I
can make exert II to electric power
poles okay that's good I'm gonna I'm
gonna get the bullets out of this to
fill the turrets because I have a funny
feeling I filled this one over here with
some already okay yeah that's I I forgot
to fill the other one where are the
turrets there's one there is there two
turrets or three turrets I put I put
three turrets generally in like a
triangular formation they should be able
to protect us we don't know where the
aliens are kind of gonna come from first
like in the last episode I definitely
know that you guys did not see an alien
attack and we were actually started on a
different map before this when we got
[ __ ] in the ass but yeah it was so
awesome yeah awesome
what we had to restart because the
resources weren't in line with
everything else so we were just so boned
by not having what we needed but uh no
electric drills are [ __ ] enormous yes
and they work way better like so harder
so I'm going to uh deconstruct two of my
steam or my bernie ones over here uh-huh
give it the old electric drill situation
that's good thank you
and where the [ __ ] does he poop out the
iron ore I can't even tell you
zoom in you can see the chute is about
the same looking as the other ones I
don't I think it's right there yeah it's
it's the orange there the copper look
yeah okay yeah and then I just need to
place like poles to connect up with your
electric grid right yes exactly and you
kind of want to space them out gent
nicely because it can get pretty late
into the game it just gets really
sporadic of where you put these things
so just try to keep it organized but
then just understand the cast is going
to ensue eventually so for those of you
out there who don't know we're hooking
up electricity to our mining drills Bob
is putting an electric mining day thing
over there he's gonna make more poles
and then connect that I just connected
the copper one to that one so the copper
is chugging out very quickly and very
rapidly and then everything else is
gonna go wonderfully and nothing will go
wrong
hopefully Bob uh yeah there's nothing to
go wrong you know it's fine it's
probably fine oh I don't like the
probably that you're putting out here
all right I pay I set up an electric
mining thing hey good job I did it okay
the only thing with that is now the
copper from the electric one is popping
out in the wrong side of the tracks no
it's been like that the whole time I oh
never mind it's fine don't worry about
it okay I'm not worried about it
it makes this copper just the same so it
I did not attempt to fix that okay good
enough I believe you you believe I made
no attempt to exit that's not good
that's just what I expect out of our
dynamic just that's about right for Bob
you know what good effort
good good attempted try try yeah hey
well uh I'll fix it later don't worry
yeah okay I'm just gonna put the last
new drill we'll go in the the iron area
and then that should be golden for what
we're trying to do later so the next
thing that I'm going to do is I'm going
to string these up ah I'm out I'm out of
poles I got more poles you need more
poles now I'm making more poles they're
easy to make but the next thing I'm
doing is stringing this up over here
because eventually we're going to
replace all of the inserters with
electric concerns which are faster and
more efficient than burner inserters so
is - how how do electric mining rigs
compare to the burner mining rigs am i
are they
I've got to where I had four previously
is that going to keep up or is that not
really going to keep up um I think it's
about one electric is worth three
burners or maybe two burners one's worth
two burners so they they work really
well you'll see you seem to be pretty
efficient I've got another electric
drill I could put up you only put it on
the coal and get rid of these other
burners yeah go ahead do it up do as
many as you can because there's
literally no limit to what we can do it
turns electricity we just need to keep
providing more and more power to it I
thought you were gonna say there's no
limit to what we can imagine well let's
not go that far there's definitely a
limit to what we can imagine and I'm
trying to kind of stuff look this is a
dick in balls
look at how I imagined that I I don't
know wow I never even thought of that
before you will never imagine things
like that before so you've never
imagined dick and balls
oh no so no or whatever sounds most
convincing so no all right so how do I
make electric gravity goos um iron oh I
just need iron and I can make him yeah
exactly they literally just take copper
and iron and you sticks those together
and then you put them in RAM them
together as fast as you can [ __ ] them in
there just put them right in there I
just [ __ ] them in there but I've never
got [ __ ] your father [ __ ] your father
[ __ ] you
I've never heard something described
just [ __ ] it right in there
so uh that's new is that your slogan for
your table hey bobblehead [ __ ] ready
don't worry about is [ __ ] it right in
there yeah I just it'll take care of
itself just [ __ ] it on right in there
it'll be fine all right I'm just
extending the burner operation because
we're eventually gonna need a lot more
stuff and now I can start and pull it
replacing it with all right well those
are some really inefficient poles and
perhaps I should change them later but
for now whatever [ __ ] it
just don't look at my life look at your
[ __ ] electric poles I literally did
not look down into bed and just cuddle I
was just like Oh where's it gonna fit oh
just generally like your whole area kind
of describes it like you're the simplest
thing is you could have had your
electric drills in line with each other
but now let's just put them one block
off to make it inferior thing I was
basing them on the burner drills that I
had which were also already [ __ ] so
it's like uh who cares oh my god three
of the four inserters are on the same
side of the burner and this last [ __ ]
it's on the electric grid okay it's not
a very well thing it still your [ __ ]
kids okay all right you know it's it's
fine it's generally acceptable I am is
it is it functioning at the same
capacity as it would be if it was more
logically constructed yes you're right
it is oh it's perfect its way to saying
yes it's perfect you're perfect perfect
what you do biz could be described as
perfection yeah that's very generous of
you to say that I love ya now that I
said it out loud I kind of regret saying
it so bad about it a little bit know a
little bit huh I'm gonna take it back if
you don't mind just that's I totally
expect that I'm gonna make more um more
electric I'm gonna reply I'm just gonna
replace all ass I'm all electric over
here baby
oh jeez oh no I'm not [ __ ] I don't thank
you so what wait
okay oh no I'm okay no non-electric
stuff you forgot one is totally powered
don't look god sakes I'm not looking
just to make just to make you happy but
I'm gonna do I'm gonna put this guy
where he belongs
uh-huh yes these are all and it's in it
symmetrical wow it's so symmetrical it
looks so much better now except for the
power lines
yeah just bite eight year old yeah
I mean effectively they were if we're
considering all things but it's like
your your area was designed by like a
city planner and my area was designed by
guys in the 15th century who did not
know electric we didn't leave any places
for powerful I don't know
yeah when electricity was first around
they're like this is a fad it's not
gonna catch on
this place is electricity I don't
understand you know I'm gonna make
myself useful and I'm gonna make sure
that we're still producing ammo and oh
we're out of copper oh no you just needs
needs iron for that I'm gonna go around
and reload all the turrets
thank you but more in them or whatever
you do best you the bestest that ever
was I'm gonna I actually need to make
more boilers for the sodam engine we
have plenty of science going on now or
we do not actually all right I need to
make some more gears that so we should
make another assembly plant where it
producing gears right yes yeah yeah
right so I'm gonna make an assembling
machine mm-hmm yeah yeah I like this all
right and then I'm gonna place it hang
on yeah okay hang on I'm taking on top
of this the gears are turning it's okay
you can feel it right you're gonna have
your l your power poles in the way man's
[ __ ] me up I'm sorry
move it then how far can this Ricci
things reach oh you can reach pretty
pretty far if I go like that
then never know am I gonna like it's so
ugly
shut up yeah I'm thinking okay
like that no not that and there go and
then you're gonna make you get you make
whoa oh gosh is that's not that's a
burner one not an electric one all right
how do I get my electric ones out a good
question huh yeah
ah boink okay ah [ __ ] oh wow
nothing is pumping okay is that enough
back if you want to know a cool thing if
you click on our TV what's not working
oh wait I got it there it goes now it's
working but if you two made it one step
up you could have had the gear grabber
inserted into the science machine what
okay
if you two moved this assembly machine
one notch up you could have another uh
inserted right here loving it right into
the sex machine I got ya ha
like the insert is just like Oh what ooh
where'd it go now I got it now we're
cooking with gasoline and stuff okay
powers gonna go out real quick don't
don't mind a thing everything's how eat
okay I just need to make another another
few steam engines don't mind it's fine
everything's fine
it seems fine everything is fine
why would you definitely seems fine it's
definitely fun there's no question about
that
wait so is this what you had in mind or
um yes that is exactly what I had in
mind
nailed it nice I am a genius nice okay
so that if you actually handy-dandy tip
if you left-click on electric pole you
can actually see the production and
demand in live and we were actually not
meeting production needs because all of
these were not pumping out nearly enough
power we need a lot more power hmm so
I'm going to make one more do daddy oh
[ __ ] oh I could have made this such
better design I could have made this I I
can actually redo this because it's
gonna make me mad if I don't redo this
but oddly enough we're all out of time
for this episode so we're gonna keep
playing this thank you Bob so much for
joining me check out Bob's channel in
the description channel name is my scrim
in case you didn't know by his user name
wait what is my name in this game forgot
bumbles boom bumbles okay so see you
from my screaming bumbles so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always we'll see you in the next video
I had to test that worked I didn't want
to like talk out of my ass here so